all right well thank you for having
better I think it's we should take a
second and see how remarkable that is
that we're having a four day workshop on
large-scale computational theories of
the brain this doesn't happen very often
a little bit of an indicator that is our
instructions as speakers was to
encourage us to be somewhat speculative
and if you think if you're a theorist
that's what you're supposed to do but in
neuroscience it's actually often looked
down upon I'm going to so I think it's
great that we're here and I really
appreciate the Simon sister for doing
that I'm gonna talk about a large scale
theory of the brain I'm gonna talk about
the neocortex today and it's a great
following too serious talk which is
great I'm gonna talk about a theory
about how the your cortex itself may be
organized around locations in specific
government proposed specific neural
networks in the neocortex where grid
cell like mechanisms not grid cells per
se which are in the anthropoids if it's
l-like mechanisms representing locations
are exist in every cortical column and
that the cortex can be understood as a
location processor that's a lot to cover
here and I'm going to get into it I'm
gonna start with just this working know
there we go yes just what you may not
know no Manta is dementia is a privately
held research lab a company we're in
Redwood City California and we have
about 12 employees and we have a
scientific mission and our scientific
mission is to reverse-engineer the new
your cortex that's arguably a very
ambitious goal I understand that but
it's also realizable goal and we
shouldn't forget that we're interested
in biologically accurate theories we're
not interested in biologically inspired
theories we're not interested in sort of
advancing machine learning we want to
understand how the the neural pill that
exists in our heads actually works and
we test our theories empirically with
partnerships and and via simulation we
do have a secondary goal but it's
definitely secondary we don't spend as
much time on it we believe that cortical
Theory will be the basis for future
machine intelligence and we have an
active open source community
that's our theories and applying them
into machine learning tasks okay so
let's just get into it I'm not sure why
he's not very liable I'm gonna start
with a quote from Francis Crick DNA Fame
and a lot of part of his life he became
interested in neuroscience and he was
totally consumed with the ideas how is
it the neurons in our head could
perceive how it is we have the scene in
front of us and how could neurons be
doing this he wrote an essay in 1979
that was very influential for me it was
in Scientific American it was a special
issue about the brain and there all
these articles from famous
neuroscientists about what we've learned
about the brain and Francis kick came
along at the end he says you know what
that's great we have all this data he
says but we have no idea what the hell's
going on and let's not pretend that we
do and he says it wasn't that we were
lacking a theory his exact words were we
were lacking a broad framework in which
to apply these ideas you needed a
framework for understanding what the
brain does in which to apply theories
and hang them on to now that was almost
40 years ago and a lot has happened
since then first of all we've had
tremendous advances in experimental
techniques we're all aware of those
tremendous advances in the collection of
data and the things we can do the
question is how we've done developing a
broad framework of understanding what
the brain does well I think there's been
some success and some lack of success
one of the things that's been most
successful is the work you just heard
about the whole field of play cells and
grid cells in the media onto ronald
cortex and hippocampus that is sort of a
framework for how we map out
environments and know where we are and
you can see the excitement and interest
it goes into that field right now but
when it comes to the new your cortex
itself I argue that there hasn't been
much progress in developing this
framework and we still need that and
that's why I'm going to talk about today
now there's a artist rendition of a
brain we all know that's a human brain
just a reminder that neocortex is this
thing that wraps around the old brain
it's about 75% of the human brain in
terms of volume and if you could take
that your cortex out of your head I
always carry this napkin with me this is
my model of the neocortex it's about
this big in area if you could flatten it
out which you can't and it's about
two-and-a-half to three three
millimeters thick it is basically
everything we think about the world our
percept
in a vision and hearing and touch
mathematics language physics and so on
it's all occurring in the sheet of cells
it's quite remarkable now there's two
things about the neocortex that are in
contrast with each other one is the
diversity of functions the number of
things it's capable of doing and the
other is the commonality of the
circuitry and this has puzzled people
for a long time in terms of the
diversity of function in your cortex
it's divided into about a hundred
different regions no one really knows
how many there are multiple breeds and
for vision and touch and audition and
languages mathematics pok in languages
and written languages but mathematics
and physics music and art all cognition
occurs there those regions are connected
in this very complex hierarchy that
doesn't really look like a hierarchy
sort of like a hierarchy and this is
remarkably diverse functionality that
has led to our success as a species but
then people notice for over a hundred
years when you look at the details in
your cortex there's a lot of commonality
first of all there's these layers of
cells and then there are these
predominantly looks like the connections
that cross the layers are predominant
that information flows up and down
across the layers there's some
horizontal connections in some layers
and this has suggested a long time ago
there might be a columnar organization
to the cortex that information flows up
and down in the column and then spreads
horizontally they don't look like this
but that's the threat achill idea and
this is a remarkable similar similar
circuitry everywhere throughout the
neocortex and in different species it is
not the same everywhere there's a lot of
differences but it's also remarkably
similar at the same time and we have to
recognize that fact and it was in 1978
that vernon mal castle was the first one
to propose this big idea and if you
haven't read it you should go read his
essay he's proposed to following he said
look I'm proposed that all regions are
doing the same thing and what makes a
visual region vision is because it's
hooked to an AI and what makes an
auditory region auditories because it's
hooked to a near incredible idea I put
that up there right over with you know
Darwin's idea of evolution he said that
the diversity of species they're all
based on one algorithm a mouth cancer
sayings the diversity of our cognitive
functions is based on one basic
algorithm he then went on further to say
that the functional unit of the
neocortex is a cortical column and
that's a debatable thing what it is it
but this for the purpose of my talk
today I'm just gonna say take a square
millimeter of course
and in a human there's about 150,000 of
those and then he said the obvious he
said look understanding the cop what the
column does is the key problem in
neuroscience if you understand that then
you understand your cortex and then you
understand 70% of the brain sounds
simple but that was his proposal and
it's so radical that today many people
still don't believe it
it's like hard to imagine what that
could be but I take that as gospel
acknowledging the fact that our
differences but there's still something
common going on here now one of the
problems in solving this problem is that
the core of a comms are incredibly
complex the circuitry in the cortex is
one of the most complex things you've
ever seen and within one square
millimeter of cortex is a hundred
thousand neurons there's good guess
about 500 million synapses 500 million
there's more than six layers there's at
least ten yes question why am i
concerned about understanding your
comments I've seen a leaf on a tree no
not at all I don't see that analogy
understanding cells and so where is the
tree in this in this scenario here okay
the rest of the brain so you're are you
arguing am i afraid if we understand can
we understand the neural cortex about
the rest of the brain necessary for
understanding understand exactly yet I
don't think it's either necessary nor
sufficient you agree that understanding
what the cortex does in the calm does is
big idea good idea I think understanding
what the calm that maybe is a good idea
I just don't think that is a necessary
sufficient for understanding what the
cortex does well all the circuitry that
it cortex has is contained in here
there's some exceptions I'm not talking
about the thalamus and there's all the
obviously connections to subcortical
areas but there are no other know one of
the reasons that mountain castle picked
the cortical column because every is an
earth-type every cell type exists in
that in that block
every type of connection exists and
basically every type of physiological
response that repeats over the cortex is
contained in that so there isn't another
place for the cortex to do things so if
you believe in some magic it's going to
happen someplace else perhaps but I wish
you accept the fact that this is a very
important problem and and if we can
understand that we should go forward
with that all right great
anyway back to the quarter comm it's
extremely complex and you know there's
at least a dozen or ten or more cellular
layers there are dozens and dozens of
different types of cellular pathways
occurring here and they've been
documented over the decades within the
column in between columns
there's an entire hip inhibitory cell
network which is even actually more
interesting than the excitatory cell
network and and I we know that there is
a significant region the region
variability in this thing's there's more
cells we heard that and talked yesterday
more cells in certain levels fewer and
other is more connectivity and so on but
still there's something common out here
and it's been tugging at people for a
long time how do we understand that you
may not like my yesterday but I'm going
to walk through what I think is going on
here okay now how do we attack this
problem our approach is the following
this is what we've done in our research
we start with an observation that the
cortex is constantly predicting its
inputs now what do I mean by that when I
pick my touch if I reach my hand over
here I have an expectation we're gonna
feel and if I move it up here a bit
different expectation and when I touch
this thing I have a different
expectation in fact every time I touch
anything I have an expectation when I'm
going to feel and I know that because it
was different if this felt like jello or
milk or something else
we had a real rough edge on I would
notice it so there's this sort of
background prediction which is going on
is happening in vision as well in an
audition and you notice your when your
predictions are inaccurate it's not that
your your predictions are conscious
you're not aware of this when we started
with this I wrote an entire book about
this problem called on intelligence that
brains building a predictive model of
the world and then the kind of question
is how does the cortex and now therefore
how does the column learn predictive
models of its input and I argue it does
if it's got to make predictions anywhere
in the cortex it's going to be making
predictions in every cortical column and
how would it do that so let me just walk
through some basic circuitry here
because I wanted
pick some parts of the circuitry in the
quarter of a column which I'm now going
to try to put a theoretical framework
around so let's just talk about
feed-forward pathways into a cortical
column it doesn't matter where you're
talking there are two sources of input
one is directly from other cortical
regions and the other is through the
thalamus this is true the thalamic input
is true not just for the primary central
regions but as Mary Sherman in regularly
of arguing for many years it is a part
of every cortical column that input
comes in to every color column from the
thalamus and directly from cortex if
that's available now remind ourselves
that when it arise primarily in layer
four not exclusively Lea 4 but arrives
in layer for your input layer in the
cortex
it forms less than 10% of the synapses
on layer 4 cells in the v1 it's
estimated about 7% so where all those
other synapses on layer 4 is coming from
there's many coming from other layer 4
cells but about 50% of them are coming
from layer 6a this is a common repeated
observation in cortex the 1/2 the input
coming to layer 4 is coming from 6a and
I've noted it here in blue because it
doesn't appear that those inputs are
strong enough to make the layer 4 cells
fire but they must be doing something
important that's a lot of neural pill
but just not doing something so
something is happening here in this
thing then layer the classic view is
that layer 4 projects 2 layer 3 layer 3
projects 2 layer 5 this is you find this
in every textbook but here you see a
similar thing between lower layer 6
layer 6b there's a similar sort of
bi-directional connection to layer 5
those cells look very similar is a very
unique pattern though how they look and
so there seems to be this sort of
parallel construction going on here
between 6a and 4 and 6 B and 5 this is a
very common circuitry you see this
everywhere there are two types of
outputs to a cortical column there is
fun the upper layers predominantly layer
3 but also later to it projects to other
areas of the cortex and then there's
another output from layer 5 the thick
tufted cells which projects to the
thalamus becomes then input to another
region and also as Murray has argued for
many years it has a motor component and
we've seen this everywhere so every
column seems to have a motor output as
far as we know
I want to remember this [ __ ] I'm gonna
try to develop a framework for
understanding what's going on here in in
the rest of this talk now I'm going to
do it using this as my my outline for my
talk
this represents the alpha half of my
talk and it also represents the outline
for how we've gone about our work over
the last 13 years and we've been trying
to tackle this a piece at a time
and building up a more complex models as
we go we started by asking a simple
question how does a layer of cells learn
predictive models of sequences like like
a melody I can learn a melody I can
predict it I'm always constantly
particularly next note in the melody
sequences are used everywhere in the
brain we use them in our motor behaviors
we use them in visual inference and
auditory inference it's a common thing
that brains have to do they have to
learn sequences and play them back that
took us many years to figure this out
it's a very complex story we first
published it it's about two years ago in
March of 2016 in frontiers we now have
about five papers on this particular
thing there's a lot of detail in that
how that works we then went on to I'm
going to go through some of this in a
moment here we then after we did that we
we wanted to extend that model to how it
is that we can learn predictive models
of sensory motor sequences because
inputs to the brain and to the cortex in
it to any column are constantly changing
but most of the time you're changing
because we move not because the world
knows so we'll call that essentially
motor sequences and we we achieved that
by doing two things we we deduced that
there must be an efference copy or motor
drive location signal and I'll talk
about that in a second and we added a
second a column a second layer in this
in this model we published that this
last year in October of 2017 we when we
did that and we published us in that
paper we talked about the nature of this
location signal but we said look we
deduced it must exist but we didn't know
where it come from came from we didn't
understand the nature of it we
speculated in that paper that we could
study the answer ronald cortex which has
another mechanism for representing
locations the grid cells and perhaps
will we be finding motivation there for
how it is be happening in the
cortex by the time that paper came out
we had already figured this out we think
we figured it out at least we have a
good model for it
we believe that layer 6a is actually
doing something very similar to what
grid cells are doing in the answer on
aquatics I call it grid cell like it's
not exactly the same but it's using some
of the same tricks that we believe are
going on in the in Toronto cortex were
preserved and actually happening in
every cortical column and now we have a
complete sensory motor inference model
here we have not extended it further we
realize that objects in the world are
composed of other objects and I'm going
to get to this into more detail and so
we believe that each cortical column is
actually learning composite objects and
that you can now explain 6a and 6b is
actually two different location layers
representing two different structures
and layer five is a composite upper
layer I will get to that this has not
been published so we did put that a
poster at this a cosine this year and
manuscripts are underway but I can talk
about it because we're supposed to be
speculative where I want to get to is I
want to talk about what's going on here
but you can't understand what's going on
here and Charlie tell you something
about what's going on here so we kind of
build this up and I have to bring you
with me otherwise I can't just explain
this so I'm gonna gonna start over here
and we talk about how is to some of the
key points and how we think that a layer
of cells we think even in input layer
way for is learning sequences we started
with the neuron where our predictions
were approaching the brain occurred have
you ever thought about that
if the brain is making predictions all
over the place how does that happen you
could have a separate population of
cells that makes predictions which is
true but we actually think that every
pyramidal neuron is a prediction machine
now if you think about a pyramidal
neuron has anywhere between five it's
30,000 synapses ten percenter more close
to the cell body proximal they can make
the cell fire 90% of them are too far
away and for many many years people had
no idea what would the 90% of the
synapses in that cell we're doing
several clever labs have come up and
some of people here in the room have
worked on this they've discovered that
dendrites are active processing elements
and if you have somewhere between 8 or
20 synapses on a dendritic branch and
they're near each other within 40
microns of each other and they fire and
they activate around the same time then
it generated dendritic spike
and the generate expect will travel to
the summer and have a large effect if it
was an NBA spike it will depolarize the
soma but not enough to make the cell
fire and it can lead to a sustained
depolarization so now people argued is
that useful because it doesn't make the
cell fire what good is it we have
proposed the following that the proximal
synapse is defined the classic receptive
field of the neuron but the distal
synapse is when they they close these
dendritic spikes they put the cell in
Ettore depolarize what we call a
predictive state the cell is saying I've
recognized the pattern that is typically
preceding myself becoming active and I'm
depolarized and the advantage of that
and this is our pothinus that the
polarized neurons fire sooner than
nondepolarizing
neurons and they inhibit other neurons
nearby and then lead to a sparser
activation and I'll walk through the how
that works in a moment and a neuron can
predict its activity in hundreds of
different contexts because they have
thousands of synapses the next thing we
have to do to understand this model is
oh I'm sorry here's a picture of how we
model neurons and I'll show off to
everything we do it this is a sort of a
picture of how we do it in software our
neurons have arrays of dendritic
branches if you will that act like
coincidence detectors as far as I know
were the only people in the world who
build sophisticated networks using model
neurons with active dendrites I don't
see how people can feel like they're
modeling the brain by using point
neurons I'm going to talk now about
sparse activations this is key to the
whole theory as well if you look at a
population of cells let's say 5,000
cells in one layer in one column at any
point time there'll be some activation
on those cells and it's sparse so I'm
going to see using an example here
listen we had 5,000 neurons and 2% were
active at any point in time and another
point in time 2% were active another
point in time - percenter active just
for grins so we have a hundred active
cells a couple of observations we can
make first of all how many different
things can we represent with that it's
virtually unlimited it's a basically
5000 choose 100 which is 3 times 10 to
the 211 so almost infinite from our
point of view the next point is if you
randomly chose sparse activations and
you could do that all day how much would
they overlap how many cells which they
have in common and it's about two but
what's very important it's never going
to be a lot it's
very very unlikely that if you pick some
random group of a hundred cells that
there'd be a lot of cells in comments
you can do this all day long and then go
do forever and you can pick these
representations and they're a unique now
no one's going to take advantage of that
in the following ways first of all if I
wanted to recognize a pattern Asst and
the set of active cells I only need to
send form synapses to a subset of the
active cells if i form subsets to maybe
eight to twenty of them this neuron will
fire when that pattern is there you can
argue like yes but there's a large
chance that this thing could have a
false positive recognition it turns out
it's not likely at all it's very very
unlikely you can do the math on it and
we've done that you can also test it
empirically this cell will reliably
recognize that pattern on almost all
conditions the second thing now this is
the piece that I want to get you on this
slide we think this is going on
throughout the brain in any region we
think that actually what you're
representing at multiple times is a
union of patterns that is you can impose
multiple patterns at the same time in
the same set of cells so if I want to
invoke ten patterns that I have a little
bit less than a thousand cells active
maybe a little bit less than twenty
percent of the cells active and what we
can show mathematically and empirically
did this cell with its 15 synapses or
whatever will still reliably recognize
that one pattern it was designed to
recognize there's a obviously a much
greater increased risk of false
positives but mathematically an
empirically we show that is still very
very small so what we decide is the
following all of our models work this
way that with the way the cortex
represents uncertainty is through unions
of patterns and we know when it's
uncertain do you see higher activity
levels what's going on there it's a
union of patterns and when activity gets
sparser when the when the cortex is
figure out the answer to something and
what's amazing is that all the networks
I'm about to tell you about they work
with these unions that is you can
process unions at the same time you can
propagate multiple hypotheses and act on
them cut all to every connection that's
going on in the brain okay we put this
together in a single layer model to
learn sequences in prediction so you can
imagine this like layer four here I show
that layer in time 0 and time 1 I've
arranged the cells in little mini
columns with the cells and the mini
columns have the same feed-forward
receptive field
property it's not important to have many
columns it's important to have a set of
cells that have the same FIFO receptive
field property and if an input comes
along later it's going to activate a set
of a set of mini columns and you'll see
all the cells in those mini columns
become active that's what whoo boolean
bezel saw 4050 years ago and we still
see today what's going to happen now if
you have a predicted input and I'm gonna
represent that but there's a little red
circles these cells are in the new polar
ice state the same input comes along
those cells fire sooner and they inhibit
the cloud around them and you end up
with a very sparse pattern that pattern
represents the input in a specific
context and you could have millions of
these and then that activation pattern
can then predict the next activation
pattern and you can basically build up a
sequence memory we have characterized
there so at this point out it's very
high capacity even a small network like
this can learn hundreds of thousands of
transitions it can learn any kind of
high order sequences it's extremely
robust to everything the learning is
importantly unsupervised continuous and
local so there's no like global signal
going on here and it really is a
biological network we actually require
two different types of inhibitory cells
and make this work it's very detailed in
that regard just to be comfortable this
is many people have implemented this
there's many multiple source
implementations and it's actually being
applied in commercial products today
okay that was what went on here so then
we say okay how can I extend that model
to learn paying predictions of
sensorimotor sequences what can I move
that's a much harder problem so let me
just so I think we all understand the
problem here it's like this is a static
object and in when I touch it the
changes to my brain occurred because I
move and I want to be able to predict
that so we started with our same input
layer our sequence memory we said how do
we modify this to incorporate sensory
motor predictions and we said okay this
simply interests that is we need to add
a second context we have one context
which is the cells themselves we need a
second context which would be some kind
of motor related context and if we could
do that then maybe we can get the system
to do what we wanted to but what is that
correct motor related context we
for quite a while and the answer in that
was very obvious to me but it wasn't
obvious in time and I'm just going to
illustrate it with just my coffee cup
here literally I was doing this in my
office one day I say okay so imagine I'm
just touching this cup with my finger
and I'm about to move my finger and
touch in a new location and I can
predict what I'm going to feel I can
predict it right now I know I'm going to
feel and I know if I've touched the
bottom a couple feel something different
there's a little rough edge down here
and I know if I move my hand over here
I'm going to feel this little handle
here what does it take for my cortex to
do that first of all it needs to know
that it's touching a coffee cup because
that's essential and it also needs to
know where it is on the cup and it needs
to know where it will be after I move it
needs to know in the reference frame of
the cup doesn't matter where the cup is
relative to my body it doesn't matter
where my finger is relative my body it's
where my finger is relative to the cup
there's no way around this if I'm not
going to make a prediction I'm gonna
have to know where it is I'm going to be
on the cup after I move and you can just
do this yourself you can imagine what
you're going to feel when you do this
now imagine now I'm touching the cup of
multiple fingers at the same time my
hand all parts of my hand all my fingers
are making the same prediction different
different predictions but they're doing
it I'm not conscious of it but they're
doing because if anything changed I
would notice it there was a little rough
edge here or something like that that's
not normally there so this idea that
every part of your sensory your
somatosensory area is actually
predicting what it's going to feel
requires every part knows where it is
relative to the cup I'm not gonna work
through it today but the same argument
can be made for vision and the retina so
we came back and said okay we need an
object centric location signal to do
this and now I could say okay the input
layer what does it represent now it
represents a feature at a location on
the cup and every time I move that
changes and if I pulled those together
in a separate layer cells called a knob
beause it's called the object layer this
and I said this is going to be a stable
representation representing the cup and
I'm gonna associate that stable
representation with the set of features
that location I now have a definition
for a cup and I can predict what I'm
going to feel if I have that object
centric location being updated we built
these models we built all kinds of
sophistication assisted versions up I'm
not going to go through all of that but
this will learn a predictive model of
objects through movement static objects
and therefore an object is just a set of
features at locations yes I didn't say
anything about a Maps yet you said 2d
Maps I'm gonna argue that the way
locations are representing the cortex
are non-dimensional and they can be
applied to 1 D 2 D 3 D and D in a moment
so I didn't say anything about 3d
represent you're thinking good cells are
people--they're that's even questionable
by the great I think you're thinking
grid cells being 2d but I didn't say
duty okay here's a little cartoon
animation to just give you a flavor of
what we're talking about here and I want
to show this because I want to talk
about the union property a little bit so
I don't have this this is hand the
finger and I'm about to touch this cup
at some location and this is my input
layer and this is my output layer and I
have a location signal coming in telling
me where I'm going to touch I get some
sentry feature when I touch that and
what's going to happen up here you're
gonna form a union of all the possible
things that this column knows that are
consistent with that location and
feature in some sense it says like
there's three things that are consistent
without a cup of key and a ball and the
way you're going to do inference you're
going to keep moving your finger just
like if I reach my hand to a black box I
touch something I don't know what it is
until I move it several times what's
going on when you're doing that as you
move to a new location you get a new
sensory input and now that is
inconsistent with one of these things do
you start narrowing down the
representation up here you do another
position another thing you get another
location another feature bingo now you
know what it is it's the coffee cup we
realized that of course multiple columns
are being input at the same time so
imagine touching this with three fingers
at the same time each one's going to be
on a different location on the object
and each one's gonna have a different
century feature but they're all trying
to model the same thing is that we
realize if you had Longreach connections
in this output layer you can form an
association
memory between these and they could
resolve ambiguity very very quickly so
an example of that in this guy imagine
that my little thing here I have the
hand touched the cup and and three
different fingers at once so this is the
three different fingers each one's at a
different location different feature
each one on its own is M is uncertain of
what's going on each one can't tell what
it is this guy says well could be a cup
or Bowl this is a cup or a can but when
they vote across columns they quickly
settle on the right answer this is
equivalent envision imagine if you're
looking at the world through a straw and
you're trying to recognize something you
just have to move it around and and to
see the different parts you couldn't
recognize it just in one glance but if I
have multiple patches of my retina the
entire retina in some sense then all of
them can vote once and say oh I know
what this is
you think this is actually what's going
on in my four layers layers free in the
cortex okay so that again was published
last fall and and I really wanted I move
over to this guy here and talk about
layer six a and and what I'm going to
argue here is that layer six a is
something like grid cells now I'm going
to it was great that Syria gave that
very detailed call talk earlier because
I'm going to talk about yourselves in a
very broad theoretical framework and not
going to the details I'm going to point
out a few things about him and I just
want you to trust me that I know the
details I'm just not going to talk about
it today so how does that let's talk
about how location is represented in
grid cells now just remind yourself grid
cells exist in multiple modules and and
you and when you look at the entire set
of modules it encodes a location
individual good cells don't so here's a
classic example you have a rat in a room
maybe it's a virtual environment but
let's say it's a rat in the room and
what grid cells will do is they will
encode different locations in this room
and so what's born here is that these
location representations are just if I
just looked at them as a bunch of
neurons or just some sparse code and
they're unique for each room this is an
important part of good cell theory at
least in in learned environments that
would be the case and so these two rooms
here are similar but they're different
in the rat and see them different cuz
they have some sort of sensory cues in
them which tell you they're different
so the same locations in this room will
be represented by very different
activations in this room and same with
this room here so this is an important
thing these are just the the
representation vocation in grid cells if
I just looked at the population of cells
and what's active represents these
locations they unique to the room and to
the location room I'm also my individual
good cells now again I'm talking about
the ensemble of good cells key thing
here is that what ties these points
together is movement if you look at the
actual representation of the grid cell
population it tells you nothing about
dimensionality doesn't say x and y
nothing like that it's just some random
vector it looks like but what's
important about it if the rat moves from
A to C it'll say okay I have a new
representation for C and if they are
moved from A to B to C it also gets back
to C and the clever trick that grid
cells do is that once you've learned
this and sort of talked about this a
bunch once you've learned this it
implies two novel environments you don't
have to learn it again so I can be a new
environment and also I can navigate
between these and the path integration
is going to work one way to look at this
is say what's the definition of a room a
definition of a room is a set of
locations all of them not just the ones
I'm showing here that are connected
together by movement by path integration
you can move between those points and
the system knows how to do that some of
these locations have associated features
and that defines how you know what room
you're in but not all of them you don't
have to have features at everything here
you just have to have some what we're
gonna say is the following thing is
going on in every core of a column but
here what we want to know is where is
the sensor patch relative to objects in
the world and so I can define a set of
points around this coffee cup instead of
points around this pen and the same way
as before there's gonna be sort of a
grid like cell representation we're
gonna argue us in 6a that's unique to
the location and the object so a is only
on the coffee cup at this point and this
Update location updated by movement we
can say what is an object an object it's
just like over here objects is a set of
locations that are connected by movement
via past integration in this case I'm
just moving a part of my body not the
entire body some locations have
associated features notice I pointed a
location W here that is in the space of
the
it's not on the pen but it's in the
space of the pain because a virus down
here at y and I move my finger up here I
will sweep through w to get there it
doesn't mean that you have to be
touching the thing you're just within
this point that you can move between and
the way this works each object has its
own point in space is own locations of
set of locations in space and once you
treat you're trying to do is narrow down
which location you are you can downtown
which location you are exactly then you
know what cup your what object your
honor this give me this analogy can be
take you further this is explaining so
like primary and secondary sensory
cortices
what about higher-level concepts in the
brain could this be happening there too
well if you starting grid cells you
could start realising that the location
representations are dimensionless after
your question earlier if I just look at
the representation its dimensionless
what defines is the dimensionality the
space is how the path integration learns
that's what defines a dimensionality and
so you could have one dimensional space
with two dimensional space it's all
about path integration and movement the
second thing is the move rooms
themselves do not have to be physical if
I'm a cortical column and I'm getting
some sort of efference copy it doesn't
have to be physical it could be a
movement coming from some other part of
the cortex which would be sort of
movement in a different space and the
features themselves do not have to be
sensory features they can be the outputs
of other columns and so what we are
proposing is that all knowledge in the
brain is represented even abstract
concepts are represented in this way
they're represented in spaces so when
you think about mathematics your
equivalent of a movement might be a
transform you do on an occasion it's a
it's a procedure operate on and then it
moves moves the components to a new
point in the space of the problem you're
working on there's a very vague idea
here but I think it follows from mount
castles proposal from the cortical
Anatomy and from this basic idea that
this this idea if this is happening in
sensory areas it's gonna be happening
other areas in the brain as well
question yeah so any time you're talking
about movement you need to at some level
start talking in terms
timescale yes is there anything in this
model which Witchita
predicts or suggests some ruler for the
time scale yeah I didn't present it here
I rather talk about it too because this
is a bit complicated but you remember I
talked about the sequence memory earlier
that has to have time in it and and so
does sensorimotor inference has to have
time everything has to be time
everything has some sort of temporal
pattern by which it flows think of it
that way I think it was like that the
tempo or the the rhythm or the the
individual duration notes and a melody
and we have a theory about how that's
done and I kind of talking about it it's
very threat achill but I believe I their
current best guess about it is its
matrix Elves and the thumbless which
project to layer one have all the right
attributes for this and they look like
they might be doing that problem but
it's an important problem but I didn't
talk about it here okay
perfect question just leading to my next
point here okay object hierarchy okay
answer that question if I get another
question yeah yeah yeah yeah you know I
think when I talk about hierarchy let me
come back to hierarchy okay if I look to
a bigger straw
I could see immunity face right but I
look to a really tiny straw I might not
be able to see the moon face let me come
back in a second well I talked about
hockey all right I think you're asking
about compositionality or hierarchical
structure
for good stuff like I don't think about
in coyote let me talk about that we came
to realize that objects are always
composed of other objects this is gonna
get to the hierarchy here so let me
here's a classic example here is my
coffee cup on the coffee cup there is a
new mental logo I've learned to cement
the logo someplace else and now I know
that it's part of my coffee cup if this
wasn't there I'd say something's wrong
if the log would look different I was
something we'd be wrong I didn't I don't
learn the logo again because it's on the
coffee cup I have some concept of the
logo and I have to somehow science to
the concept of the cup this is turns out
that everything in the world is
structured this way every object is
composed of sub objects I lied to you
when I said they're coming there those
features on objects we don't believe
that's true we think every cop
everything in the world is structured by
structure of structure objects on
objects and if that's going to happen in
the cortex and it does it has to happen
in cortical columns and so what we think
is going on here is exactly that we see
these two member there's a 6a and 6b
there's these two parallel structures
going on
we think the 6b is actually representing
it's another exhorting principle like
layer but it's representing the space of
the compositional object in 6a is
representing the space of an attended
component of that object so in this case
if I was looking at the new mental logo
I would be representing it in a 6a and 4
but I would be positioning in the
compositional structure of the bigger
larger object and one of our employees
is Marcus Lewis is here today came
another very clever way of represent
that position of the logo on the coffee
cup using another grid cell like trick
and we think that's what's going on in
layer 5 you think layer 5 is actually
building compositional structure and
we're a layer layer 3 & 4 & 3 are
tending to sub structure so again we've
presented that mechanism in that poster
I just wanted to leave you that because
this is a key thing that has to occur in
the brain and now we can start beginning
let me talk about hypotheses a framework
for understanding what's going on here
and and this has to happen and once you
got at once that's good enough because
you can keep drilling down you can look
at a subject you can do on the logo my
logo is composed of lines and we're
and things and so you have to do it once
but then you can do the whole
compositional structure it seems like
you might get too many is that your
question you like you might get too many
unions yeah that's a very easy question
astute question which I'd rather take a
bit offline but why doesn't this break
down because why don't you form unions
that it could to form the answer is a
bit complicated but first of all that
neural tissue doesn't let you get too
dense there's there's a it breaks it I
won't let you represent too many things
there's a certain level of density of
activation that you're going to get and
and then so you're never going to get
all the cells active at once and then
the system will work it may take more
steps more movements but it slowly
builds out it's incredible how even in a
very complex system that it settles and
we don't understand all of it but I will
if you want I'll talk to you about it
later
okay I want to take one more slide about
Harkey then I wrap up this idea of thing
about this brain challenges the way we
think about hierarchy so this is the
classic view if you will you have some
sensory organ it projects to the primary
sense of reason you extract some
features you production the next review
more complex those features and then
eventually you recognize objects in the
deep Learning Network this might be a
hundred level high we're challenging
that it's not to say that this isn't
true but it's a you have to think about
it'll bit differently now we're saying
as a region actually is a whole set of
object models and the next region up is
another whole set of object models the
next reads up is another one set of
object models so how would that have you
think about that well first of all one
of the things you should know that any
input to any region always skips a
couple levels too so there's input from
LGN from the vision to b1 to b2 and so
on it gets less as you go up but what
that allows us to do it allows the
columns at different levels to also work
at different scales so if I'm if I'm
turning to something very very small in
my visual space I'm gonna argue that V
one's gonna be required to do that but
if I think it's larger like a letter and
it gets larger then v1 and v2 could do
it and then if it gets larger still v1
is no longer able to see that because it
takes up too it's outside of my
the ones looking at this tiny little
space in this thing is too big you like
the moon face so that's one thing to
think about they're working at different
scales the other thing to think about
here is that when you have multiple
sensory arrays so now I have like a
vision array and a touch array and so
I'm looking at this coffee cup and
touching at the same time what's going
to happen here you can have invoking
models in the visual adult and they
somatosensory Harkey and in the visual
hierarchy at the same time and these
guys can collaborate across modalities
because they're all modeling the same
object the same argument I made before
about long-range connections between
certain light layers routing the columns
to vote applies here too and what you
see in the cortex you see connections
like this that don't make any sense in
the higher in the classic hierarchy
you'll see connections in a secondary
region projecting to a circular region
another modality to a primary region
another modality
going up all over the place that doesn't
make any sense in this model but it
makes a lot of sense in this model
because these guys can all vote the
corpus callosum can be combined in my
left hand in my right hand because
things are often touching the same
object and so on okay I'm gonna end it
there there's a bunch of biological you
think it could just possibly be true
yeah
wouldn't mean a primitive object what
I'm arguing is that even columns and b1
I'll talk about that in the next slide I
get to this even comes in b1 are
recognizing complex objects you don't
think of it that way but here this thing
called border ownership cells came out
of Andhra Hodge lab they found cells in
v1 and v2 they're classic receptive
fields but they only respond in an alert
environment they respond when that's
when that part of the visual field is on
a specific point of that object is if
that cell knows oh I'm on the tail of
the tiger that's I'm supposed to respond
and it doesn't respond in other places
you would expect that the respond but it
seems to be tied to various locations
that's a direct consequence that's
showing that even in v1 and v2 there's
there's some sort of knowledge about
what the entire object is and the cells
are being unique in location that's
exactly what we would predict there's
another really using a set of things are
going on right now this is very clever
experiments going on with fMRI where
they've shown signatures of grid cells
throughout the cortex not to all of
cortex but lots of it and there's some
clever experiments I won't go into it
it's not proof but it looks very very
convincing that grid cell like
properties exist through many different
regions of the cortex this stuff has
been known for a long time there's sort
of sensorimotor prediction even in
low-level sensory areas like v1 and v2
there are cells that become active
during a saccade before the cicadas
finished that they become active before
the cicadas finish and there there would
have become active one the cicadas
finished so after the secod there's a
fixation we'd expect that cell to be
active and itself becomes active during
the secod it's as if it's hard to
explain that but if you if you think
about it this way you say well that Kel
is being given its new location it says
given this motor behavior here's what
your new location should be and it has a
model what it's looking at it says okay
I can predict what I'm going to see
totally explainable to them there's
another interesting angle thing about
from an evolutionary point of view the
people study the evolution the neocortex
that one of the predominant theories
that there are two older three level
structures that fold it on top of the
to make a six level structure those
older three level structures are roughly
equivalent to the hippocampus the anther
on our cortex and so the idea that you
might have the lower layers of the
cortex would be representing locations
the upper layers representing place
cells if you want to think of it that
way and they form this new structure is
very consistent with our point of view
here and lastly I'm gonna give you one
more observation of this and I'll be
done I remember when I first learned
about grid cells I was blown away by
them I was struck by the fact that I
never realized that I had cells in my
head my brain which are representing my
location and it's very easy to figure
this out you can just walk around in the
dark get up in the middle of night and
try to walk to your bathroom and you
have a sense for where you are there's
no clues no visual input know what it
may be there's some slight auditory
reverberations but you don't need that
you just I can say ok I'm gonna walk
over here and I know now that I'm in
front of the screen I walk back over
here I'm gonna be closer to the the
lecture and so on so I was just blown
away that he didn't realize this it's
all obvious now the same thing has
occurred to me when I think about the
world you guys look like you're out
there you don't look like you're on my
retina how come I perceive you is out
there how come I proceed my hand there's
some distance in position relative my
body I have a continuous concept where
everything is located to everything else
and I now having navigate between
everything and everything else this is
what Crick was looking for when he when
he wrote that essay like how do we
perceive the world being out there it's
now clear to me that the cortex is
actually a location processor every
single thing that the cortex does is
located in space and you can think about
the brain and so now I think about the
cortex is this location processor and
uses sensory input to figure out what
locations it's in it doesn't process
sensory input per se it produces pencil
in precise where you are and it models
objects in space is based on how they
move within their own spaces so that's
my end of my argument there I would
speculative I did my bet my goal and I
want to thank this is the entire team in
the Mendte this is a group of myself and
these other five people some of them
here today sort of the core research
team this is a collaborative effort we
do this all day long well most days and
right these things build models and test
them thank you very much
[Applause]
yeah thank you the differences when
yours it sounds like you are building
their model partly out both the
mathematical question of what it takes
to represent space what kind of
information flows are necessary as I see
your instincts so we have to have a
signal from here we have to have this we
have to combine them this way but on the
other hand you're also working at what
is it cortex what people measured a few
years ago ideal brain would exist on the
other side of the universe we got the
paper you sent me yeah it's quite
different I think we should try to
explain it what are these things are a
conjecture in which are I don't I never
think about that way I never think about
what is mathematically expedient
physicists physicists think that way I
don't think that way I look at the
anatomy they say that's what it is
and I don't ask is it the best way I
said that's the way it is we want to
understand that they may be much better
ways of doing this I don't know our goal
I said this up front our goal is not to
look for biologically inspired theories
our goal is explain the neuro pill and
I'm going to end it at that other people
physicists perhaps yourself and others
can say oh what's the better way of
doing this we don't start with the math
we actually apply mathematics later I
didn't show any of the craisins here we
can talk about this stuff but to me it's
all about starting with the anatomy and
physiology and sort of deduction about
what might must happen and then try to
figure out those things
in Mt
you know I don't know that work
I think of MT is part of sort of the
settle aware pathway in the visual
system right I'm not familiar the work
you're reciting there so I can't comment
about that I don't know I can't answer
that question I can't answer this for
example I didn't mention this in the
talk but it's been somewhat related
it's been noted the course are what and
where pathways and vision the dorsal and
ventral streams but there are also
they've been seen in audition of
somatosensory as well so the arguments
been made that this is a constant theme
and this algorithm this call a calm has
to solve both the way I think about that
I was I was describing he right now I
was a what wave or what pop it's like
modeling objects in space and the where
pathway equivalent would be in my body
space so I'd be modeling structures
around my body space so I know where
things are relative to my body where my
different parts of my body are relative
to things but it wouldn't tell me what
they are
and so a classic when you Clara if you
if you damage the dorsal pathway the the
the where pathway you can recognize
objects but you know how to reach them
in the end gamma is a ventral pathway
you can't recognize objects but you can
reach them and be surprised that you
reach them so I think the same algorithm
will work in both cases it's just a
different spaces different sort of
spaces there they're working in and we
haven't worked that out in any detail
and I can't answer the question you
asked me I'm sorry about that yeah the
bank you reckon is a very first object
well doesn't recognize the very first
object it has to learn the very first
object
any like mathematical functions that we
can use here that are in deep learning
like basically people use linear
functions activation yeah yeah we don't
think along those lines with deep
learning we think I learned I didn't
talk about the learning rules in our
neurons we rely on synaptogenesis and
finally synapses and other things going
on all the learning rules are sort of
biologically very deeply biologically
inspired but we don't we don't sort of
satisfy some sort of energy function or
that's not what would that's what's
going on there's no back propagating
error signals these are all local
learning rules everything we do is local
learning rules and so essentially if you
want to ask how do I learn something new
is pretty simple pretty simple in this
very in a very simple plastic way if I
just said I don't know where I am I
could just start assigning myself a
brand new location like this pick a
location there's some new thing I don't
know what it is pick a location and then
start building a map around that
location I can be simultaneously trying
to recognize this is something I know as
Factory actually believes is going on
you're actually constantly building new
things at the same time you're
recognizing old things if the learning
and the inference occur in parallel to
eyes to things to eyes and then color
right the coracle comm doesn't know what
its inputs represent has no idea it's
the axons look like axons sodium spikes
look like sodium spikes that's that's
all there is to it and and somehow
you're asking like well where does color
come from there's been some very work on
this and I'm trying to remember the guys
name he wrote the book why is the bell
why is the why is the bell not sound
like rad or something like that that's
there we go sorry there is there's the
man if you want understand our problem
readers book yeah
I'm sorry I didn't know you're here yeah
your elemental thing when you were
starting out on this I think your your
focus on temporal sequence predictions
yeah I suppose we started a paradigm of
constraint satisfaction that's because
you could look at it the temporal our
sequence prediction space it could be
kind of a constraint propagation and
predicting if you look at it from a
structural standpoint rather than an
attempt for old standard I don't know
how can you look at it without a
temporal standpoint I'm missing that
well sequences are temporal by nature
right that's that's the whole point of
it I'm just saying it doesn't
necessarily correspond to temporal
information and wait with receiving my
speech is a is a temple structure right
and I might be named the hook here okay
yeah my space is the temple structure
and the order someone's gotta that's
your phone then maybe it's maybe it's
commenting on your question I don't know
like serious smarter than you think I'm
not sure what your question is we
understand that it's a when I thought
about sequence when I was talking about
you know ordered sequences in sensory
motor sequences are not ordered they can
go three in any order but but the temple
structure is what's essential there and
we don't view it as we just trying to
learn that temporal structure what
follows what follows what follows what
and how can you do that in a very robust
way and I didn't go this I have a whole
talk so I can do about the sequence
memory chose how it's really clever how
we can decide can the contract multiple
sequences at the same time and make
multiple dictions at the same time and
in sort of like recognize sub components
of other sequences and so on but I don't
know I don't understand your question
so like we talked about it there's a
number of us here today from nomensa so
I think I'm supposed to I don't buy Pete
going one more question
oh we stopped I'm sorry so look I'll be
around old today and tomorrow and the
next day so and number of us here too if
you want to talk about it so thank you
again
[Applause]